au début de la pandémie la stratégie
suédoise de nos confinement a suscité
beaucoup d'intérêt on se demandait si
cette approche pourrait être viable à
long terme
mais à partir de l'été et en particulier
cet automne la situation sanitaire s'est
aggravée au point où l'on conclut
maintenant que le modèle suédois a été
un échec en mars alors que les pays
européens imposent déconfinement ferme
la suède fait bande à part
[Musique]
l'amdh erstein l épidémiologiste en chef
et l'architecte et le visage de l'
approche singulière suédoise de mauvais
centres de vote pour notamment sociable
assure un facteur dans des gorges
chaudes
la suède fait appel à la bonne volonté
de sa population plutôt qu'à la
coercition
elle recommande la distanciation
physique et le télétravail
le port du masque n'est pas recommandée
et est peu répandue on interdit les
réunions de plus de 50 personnes
sauf dans les fêtes privées et les jeans
les restaurants les événements
corporatifs et laissant d'achat le but
mettre en place des mesures soutenable
sur plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
tous les regards sont tournés avec
espoir vers cette nouvelle façon de
faire
swing ou des barreaux acteurs mais
understand elle ne fait pas l'unanimité
il est adulé par certains critiques et
par d'autres
la grande question est ce que la proche
suédoise est la voie à suivre ou même
dans la catastrophe
au printemps déjà le nombre de décès par
capita en suède est bien supérieur aux
moyennes européennes canadienne ou même
états unienne les décès ont lieu en
majorité dans les résidences personnes
âgées ou des notes managed to protect de
mosport nos hôpitaux de mossoul de louis
le gouvernement défend sa stratégie en
blâmant les manquements dans ses foyers
[Musique]
malgré les critiques le pays garde le
cap aussi en der stegen elles nient
viser l'immunité collective mais il
croit que l'immunité collective peut
être un effet secondaire de son approche
est qu'elle protégera le pays d'une
seconde vague
une étude révélera que à la fin de la
première vague seulement 7,3 pour cent
des habitants de stockholm possède des
anticorps contre lacko ville
loin du 50 à 80 % requis pour obtenir
une immunité collective
[Musique]
à l'automne les hôpitaux suédois sont
submergés à ce jour le nombre total de
décès par capita en suède et jusqu'à 10
fois plus élevés que ceux des pays
voisins
deux fois plus élevé que celui du canada
il approche celui des etats unis
mi-novembre ces chiffres force la suède
à se rallier aux méthodes d autres pays
projetant max entend le trust corp
projet strenx un style pur bonheur on
recommande le port du masque
le gouvernement s'est doté d'une loi lui
permettant de fermer les commerces
[Musique]
l'espoir de la stratégie suédoise est
devenu déception
[Musique]